i'm a big fan of your work
congratulations um do you think
that the jurassic park movies exist
in the world of godzilla versus kong and
has your character just not seen
the jurassic park movies oh wow
that that's that that's great because
yes that's exactly why we love this film
so much
you know this these possibility
possibilities
of seeing these monsters that imagine
that they actually existed
i mean there's no record having you know
like a massive
gorilla like king kong back in the days
but it would have been fantastic it
would have been phenomenal
um i think i think we should do a new
jurassic park with
uh simmons playing a key role there
somehow you know what i mean it's that
that's a great idea we should pitch that
together man
got it so this is a jokey question but
bear with me
um every time that we write about
godzilla versus kong
on collider uh the commenters on
social and facebook all say why don't
they just kiss
so my question for you is did adam
wingard ever tell you
why godzilla and kong don't kiss in the
movie
because they show it to mama tambien
they thought ah that's too much maybe
not us
no no no we should not do that i think
they
it was on the script but then you know
godzilla's and kong's agents complained
about it
and that's that that was the end of it
that that's a great answer thank you
um if you were not in this movie uh
would you be rooting for godzilla or for
khan
i i am rooting for kong and i
i was always rooting for kong and i will
always root
for khan i'm a kung man okay one of the
things though
i would imagine as an actor obviously
you're making this movie well before
you're seeing the finished
vfx what is it like actually for you
this is a movie where you really need to
see it to sort of take in what it's
actually going to be
what was it like for you seeing the
finished uh effects and
watching them fight it is you you you
uh make a great point right there
because uh look
the number one tool in any actor is
imagination
you have to have your imagination finely
tuned
at all times and this is a great
opportunity
to explore that in a deep deep way
of course we have you know the uh
production design
drawings and the tests and all kinds of
guidance you know that you can use but
basically you
you imagine the rest of it and the
previous films
that helps a lot you know having watched
the godzilla films and the kong films
you know what it is and you know how the
monsters look like
and how they interact with every actor
so they
the the the the previous revolutionaries
made our work easier my last question
for you
i am actually very excited for let the
right one in
series i think i think you in this role
is actually great
um can you say can you talk about what
excites you
about doing this pilot and the series
i i love to hear that great that you
love that because as many
millions of fans around the world i love
the swedish film
when i saw that i thought it was a
beautiful piece of work
this is not only a vampire story it's a
it's a deeper type of story you know it
talks about us
minorities it talks about people who are
rejected because they're different
it talks about many different things you
know i'm i'm really really excited about
you know going back to show time after
weeks
10 years ago and i'm working with andrea
and steve you know
um it's about the human experience
always and i i i i'm very very excited
about this
cool on that note i gotta stop thank you
so much for indulging my godzilla versus
kong kissing question have a great day
you got it man take care